[Music]
now we have janus papas at a house man
we have one half
of the um the old history hyenas podcast
man
no longer here that's right totally gone
that's right we tried to salvage it
yes yeah a lot of people don't know this
yeah now there's some people listening
right now who might not know about the
uh history hyenas podcast very funny
podcast with giannis pappas and
christa stefano amazing run we had a
good run
successful patreon very successful very
successful patreon
akash gets corona yes i really like this
[ __ ] down
yes knowingly infects you yes no no
no no no he does it
no
[Laughter]
akash comes in and gives half of the
new york comedy scene corona which is
yeah because chris was sitting right
next to you
and he didn't get it chris has had every
virus yeah you know that there's just
not enough room for any more in there
it's like the virus came and it's like a
crowded elevator it's like i'll take the
next one
it's like there's syphilis in there
gonorrhea is like there's no room for me
so you get corona and you had it bad i
had a bad one
it was really bad yeah real bad i had it
bad like alex had a bad no no no no no
no no
don't do that don't you dare you had it
very i had it very good
you had like hasidic levels yeah no it
was trying to god was trying to whack me
yeah that's what it felt like and i also
tried to do it you talked a lot of [ __ ]
about him i don't blame him yeah yeah
you're [ __ ] that guy
i got shot i [ __ ] he's trying to kill
me dude i got struck by lightning
the history ain't just broke up he's
trying to kill me he just wants you to
pray once
that's true i'm a death man in him bro
i'll become
saving you dude i think it's because i'm
not muslim i think they figured it out
and we should all convert and that's
what corona is here to tell us
it's here to tell us it's time to
convert mohammed was the way yeah
no my career's over this is doing great
okay so
so then you come out of corona right
yeah and and then
you immediately sabotage the history
hyena
they're like i couldn't have killed
flagrant two i gotta kill some podcasts
my own let's make this happen no what
happened what happened with
hyenas not true at all uh yeah we
we give me some pc [ __ ] no we wanted
no i'm starting i'm starting very
polished yeah we had a good
yeah three year run it was a lot of fun
i'm surprised we made it as long as we
made it with how chaotic it is and you
know how different
uh our philosophies are and stuff but we
had we had a great time we're great
friends
he's moving on to other stuff yeah i
have long days
which is i'm very excited about it's fun
i'm working with jesse again my my old
friend we did you know that we
yeah we created all the characters and
did ditch films with so that's fun and
it just came to a point where it just
got too hectic and instead of like
sacrificing the quality
of the podcast we just decided hey let's
just do other things and who knows what
happens in the future so let's rate
um that media train response guys what
spirit of hyenas buddy let it rip yeah i
think you got a little
bit dude there's nothing to let rip
that's it that was it that's it nothing
else that's it
it it got chaotic i could just say it
got chaotic i mean they were making good
money on
on patreon but they had to walk away
from that good money i was getting money
if you think i'd ever walk away
that was the only thing i had going so
it's like i'm not walking away from that
but then you did
yeah i mean you know wait are you saying
you said wait a minute
wait a minute you picked up on that
that's good it looks like it wasn't a
giannis papa's decision is that
is that what you're trying to say i'm
not saying it wasn't it was a mutual
decision we came to a point you know
when you just
literally agreed you know chris was
going to make the decision
do you know when you get to a point
where you just know it's time it's just
no you never got to that point nope i've
stayed in relationships
way too
there gets to a point like some
relationships are made to go
the distance yeah and some of them are
like you know the ones you really like
loving the webbing webbing yeah like you
guys yeah yeah yeah you guys are going
the distance yeah it's love
yeah it's work though yeah it is work it
takes work
it takes work it takes communication
even with my wife we're going to be
together forever it takes work takes
communication
and maybe um what was lacking in the
hyenas
there was the work there was the
communication there was probably
dig in but i've already almost killed
you once so i don't know if i want to go
but i really want to because we're we're
[ __ ] responders like we sniff it out
like yeah without money
yeah we sniff out [ __ ] yeah so our
instinct is to communicate
yeah excavate yeah the truth yeah
because we love both of you guys yeah
truly
and let the record show you know akash
and i had a conversation
yeah and it was basically how do we save
hyenas i
i yeah legit texted him like so we
thought
you know and i called you and i called
chrissy and i was like why don't we try
to save this maybe we could talk this
out maybe we could work through this
it's a fun podcast everybody in the
community seems to enjoy it
yes i don't think you guys were close to
where you could have gone i think you
were very popular within the comedy
community and within like the comedy
adjacent community but
you hadn't reached that you know casual
level where like even the casuals know
about it so i saw a lot more growth for
it
and oh gosh i'm like yo let's step in
here you know let's see if we can use a
little bit of goodwill and muscle
and make this thing happen and then both
of you guys were stuck in your family
great chemistry is rare i think yeah you
guys had it
yeah great chemistry and that's where i
was also like aside from
loving them individually together great
chemistry so rare
i always want to preserve that as mine
we have to make chrissy's show
bomb on tv so he has to come back and do
his i think tv will do that for you but
we can help
should we do it should we try to drive
the ratings down
far enough i think the only we have to
remove everything from chrissy's life
where he has to come back to you
yeah i think if akash can get corona and
give it to chrissy mm-hmm
and then we can even it out even i can
do this yes
i can do that if not mark mark will get
it yeah we need a carrier
it takes a lot it's going to take a lot
to give it to him
very resistant what would have kept it
going what would have kept the show
going is there is there a thing
maybe i think what did you need to keep
it going um
i uh you know my history i come from the
internet
yeah i feel like that i'm dedicated to
i'm dedicated to
the thing that you guys are doing right
here this is what i'm dedicated to
i spent three years completely focused
and dedicated to that
so it's like i think i know where i made
my mistake because when i strayed from
that
how'd you stray i just started you know
i wanted to get the half hour
for hyenas he's saying he had a great
shoe
here in miami for a year that went
nowhere i took aol two-point lead which
was great money and i was interviewing
athletes
you were looking for the industry to
validate i was looking yeah i was doing
that i was you know me and nate we're
friends
don't do that don't it just doesn't do
that i'm going to buy a ferrari
yeah but i recommend you not doing that
no
it's you 348 but you might get the 355
you did it
who knows by building this yeah and then
doing it on your
get a porsche terms dude it's not it is
but don't [ __ ] with the corporations
yeah no that works networks are horrible
yeah unless you want to drive a nice car
yeah i mean you know but you did it you
built something first
fully yes yes and then i fees i tease
obviously
i love what you've done and i've always
admired what you've done we've had these
conversations
off there's time so you were committed
to the internet you're committed to
youtube
and and did you feel like because of the
opportunities chris was getting
did that infringe on your guys ability
to like
lean into the internet no it was uh i i
think uh
the the focus was scattered we started
the focus started going a lot of places
yep
and you know i don't know how much you
could keep up the quality of something
when the focus is
all over the place gotcha yeah yeah i
think that's possible
you know but at the same time as you
guys grow you're going to get new
opportunities
yeah and we you got to take advantage of
them yeah you know what i mean like
i see yeah i see how you thrived
on the internet and i witnessed it in
real time it was like
really exciting for me as like a young
comic
and seeing somebody like take ownership
in and what they did it was like super
inspirational for me
you know and um i'm very grateful that i
got to witness it because it made me
realize there was a possibility for
myself to do something like that like i
didn't have to [ __ ] pucker up every
time i was at the cellar or pucker up at
these [ __ ] stupid events
so it was great um i would say it's
directly responsible for your success
yeah that's what i would say yeah i
think i just said that yeah but
you're doing you're going pc about it i
mean i would go no i was inspired by you
yeah you know i mean
it let me know that there was a way to
do it you know 100
um and uh so i think that's great but i
also think that like
there are different strengths that can
fit into different parts like i think
chrissy i think he will flourish like if
chrissy was born
10 years before he would be the biggest
star on tv
yes he is built for and this is not a
criticism it is a compliment
but he is built for an industry
structure
because you can put him in so many
different slots and he will succeed
right like very different character but
you know how zack galifianakis just
takes over anything he's in as himself
yeah chrissy can do that with his
personality but he can like i could have
him host the [ __ ] bachelor
and he's gonna have fun with it yeah or
you could have him
do uh maybe a character in a tv show
like the joey character in blossom
you know what i mean and like he could
have those different things so it is
weird that you guys are maybe being
pulled in different directions but i
think that
the directions are being pulled in
actually suit yourself
better totally and i think that's why it
came to a natural end because why does
it have to end
because we were wild we were very wild
we said whatever and you couldn't be as
wild
because you could be as well but he
couldn't be as wild because he has these
corporates i'm sure that's the way he
felt and are you doing a podcast with
sally
there he's got to say poop instead of
[ __ ] you know what i mean so
i assume is there no cursing on on the
podcast is sal
there's no cursing on it no no cursing
that i'm not allowed to do that saddest
news i've heard they don't curse this
whole time they don't i'll be honest
i'm still impressed yeah because i never
watched it and thought
wow they're not cursing like when i see
the clips on instagram
yeah i never noticed they weren't
cursing yeah righteousness and ratchet
yeah boys you do that that's another one
right just in ratchet they don't curse
but you don't notice that they're not
cursing yeah interesting so he felt a
little bit conflicted he could
you guys leaned into being wild and then
these other things that
he was doing stopped his ability to be
wise i don't want to speak for him but
those two things seem like they're at
odds but you're a wild boy
i'm always wild i go too far all the
time yes yes
okay some point texting joe rogan texas
case maurice is too much even even when
i posted oh yeah
which i thought was funny
i understand we're out of context you
can't say it's not funny it's not
funny yeah why is it funny because there
was contrast
chris nicknamed you the fuhrer and it
was funny our fans thought it was funny
yeah because if you just have a picture
of hitler there's no context i get it
uh within the comedy world he's
excellent you just see
i am wrong this guy is racist he wants
to kill me i am wrong
how about that i'm wrong i make mistakes
all the time is this the weekly combo
during history hyenas just
i mean he was chris was known as the
wild one on our
shot yeah so he was known as the wild
one yes so he was uh we were kind of
like ren and stimpy we were kind of like
beasts and butthead
yeah you know i was like the one i was
like you know thought i was smart but
i'm stupid and he was just like the wild
one that was like yeah yeah just kind of
yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so it's like we were a
cartoon we'd be like running stimpy or
beavers butter
and he was the wild one he was the one i
constantly had to be like chris i don't
know if you could say that so
he was known kind of as the wild one
right until you got on instagram
huh no until i got on twitter and then
when you're on twitter twitter yeah
twitter is where i got so many like
you're so verbose that is like you can't
even notice
i just do what i want but when you just
post a picture of
like shultz's hitler then the wildness
is clear i
understand how if he chrissy wanted to
do those other things
and you didn't how that could be a
conflict of interest
yeah but i can't blame chrissy for
wanting to do those things he blames him
no you can't blame anyone for anything
they want to do
also you guys got sorry to interrupt but
like also when when people got kids kids
exactly
it's like it's a totally different thing
you're going to lean into the thing
that puts food in your baby's mouth yeah
in your decision in your situation
that's continuing to be a wild boy on
the internet like you do
and in christie's he's probably like nah
this is doing these network shows where
i get this guaranteed money i don't got
to worry about these different things
i don't know how to be any other way and
so i realized and then
i realized i was like i can't i can't do
it the other way
so why why would i even think about it
ever i can't do it
i've done it i don't like showing up to
a studio and there's a woman waiting for
me to walk me into this room and then
they do makeup before
i just don't like it just doesn't
interest me and then i can't say this i
can't say that i just
you know i i want to be free to make
mistakes
i like to make mistakes because that's
where you come up with [ __ ]
yeah once you know i mean we comedians
that we have like
that's why tv shows don't work is
because they have like a 10
success rate we have like a 90 success
rate
because we have to yeah because our
lives depend on it
yeah and when we make one mistake they
come after us and go look he made one
mistake but it's really like yeah but i
did 90 good ones yeah you know what if
you guys just did a patreon only
we discussed that and then we made the
decision not to do that
we we made that decision
man up why are you getting back to your
verona voice
but it didn't work there was nothing we
could do at this point
you know amaze what also sucks is you
can't probably say everything because
then you know
chris isn't here to whatever i can't
speak but then all right so i can't
speak for chris i can't
luckily you don't have to chris come on
in come on in
but then we also can't like be like oh i
don't think he legally can do this
podcast anymore
probably true tv was like yeah you can't
do that and no i'm just kidding
look everyone knows how funny chrissie
is
but here's how i'm going to say we can't
even if you can't be fully honest we
can't check you on [ __ ] because all
these things are
there's two sides there's two sides
we're getting part of one side there's
two sides to the story but i
also can't call you on anybody here's
what you could have done i'm in my 40s
i've been alive for long enough to know
that
the bickering and all that stuff is
pointless because when that starts to
happen you just know
all right this is time yeah it's time
it's you guys are both mature enough to
do that
it's just time yeah time it's time we we
did like seven years worth of content
together with the patreon and everything
you know and it's like
we're two crazy comics we're chaotic
comics and you know things we started to
have conflicts of interest and
philosophies and getting to comics to
work together for that long i think
the successes that we made isn't it just
as two people grow you're not going to
be the same person you were seven years
ago neither one you are if you are
that's
stupid you didn't accomplish anything
but as you grow you gotta fight to
get it back to the center and if in my
mind i
he wasn't trying to do any network [ __ ]
but i understood like yo this guy is
doing a ton of different things
so i'll hold this down as much as i can
i'll bring people in
give them corona take out their podcast
we will grow
i'll do what i need to do you go do that
yeah that's where i was thinking
and i don't know the full story but i'm
like oh if chris you want to do that
couldn't giannis be like yo chrissy
go handle that i'll try to take as much
of this bandwidth as i can here's the
difference i think i think
you guys brought this to fruition where
it's a powerhouse
where it's like we were very much at the
beginning of the climb
and i think you want to kind of at that
point that's when you really want to
double down
and get to the point where when you're
negotiating for those other things you
can make yourself
look good in those other things and kind
of dictate your own destiny
because you have the power and the
leverage to do so yeah you guys got
opportunity too quick
take him you got opportunities too quick
i didn't get any opportunities
yeah i mean like the same way you say we
make decisions yeah
i'm using the royal guy no but like
maybe chrissy got the opportunities too
quick you know like we didn't get
netflix until
way after we were a significant podcast
right
so we were in the position to go nah
this is what we do once the rocket works
comments on your [ __ ] yeah you're going
to be able to get them to do what you
want to do you know what's up and you
don't have to sacrifice the way you look
because it can hurt you
you go do a show you can hurt you yeah
yeah yeah it could hurt your [ __ ]
yeah it hurts your brand you go do some
[ __ ] dumb show and they say do it
this way
talk and then people start your fans
start hating you for it and your fans in
this era are everything
yeah they're everything i think you get
to dictate to your fans more than you
realize like you have
hours to talk to them i don't know bro
we just went through a breakup and if
you listen to what the fans are saying i
don't yeah because you stopped talking
that's no whole issue we did podcasts
together since you do podcasts but none
sit like they've all been banked so you
can't talk to the fans
directly and say yo for hours on end
like you could
as an individual hey here's the deal
here's what it is they'll eventually
understand
i also just you also i could come on
flag with two and beat around the bush
though
welcome to busch gardens baby
you